je vais démarrer avec les photos tient
des années 2000 turbin jamin castaldi il
avait quelles têtes en l'an 2000 et
installe dit c'est quoi en l'an 2000
d'ailleurs vie sexuelle
j'étais entre autres célébrités avec
valérie sur stefan wey de vienne et j'ai
quitté tf1 pour aller sur m6 pour faire
le loft très bien et ben on va voir
mortels et ouais et benjamin castaldi
regarder il était il était déjà marié
j'ai commencé très tôt moi je me suis
marié en 94
c'est à vous et à marie qu'il assure
cette femme valérie valérie benaïm
numéro quel numéro et mon physio via
étaient des jeunes et la voix c'est vrai
déjà papa c'est fou ça et là il est
entre tf1 et m6 entre j'ai pris
l'autoroute du bonheur et après après on
s'est rencontrés voilà
et voilà donc quelques années on dira qu
est ce qu'on faisait en 2018 j'étais
avec l'autre condamné
[Rires]
il est même un livre j'aime pas la
disposition de la table
daniel vous bifurquer avec gilles elie
vdev dit vous bifurquer élévé d'ovelia
va se mettre à côté de jean michel mr et
baxi narrer suisse va se décaler merci
bam bam bam bam bam bam
merci moi j'écris moi bah vous vous
restez là vous fermez votre gueule
[Applaudissements]
m vous allez vous balader sur le plateau
continental
écoutez je prends une chaise quoi vous
croyez vous croyez qu'on a un repas les
amis valérie bénaïm valérie bénaïm
qu'est ce que vous faisiez en l'an 2000
dit à tf1
j'ai tf1 ouais c'était c'était le début
de ce lancement c'est vrai oui c'est
vrai tu me rappelles de valérie bénaïm
elle était déjà superbe elle était
sublime
regardez la garde et la regarder à la
médaille mais c'est comme ça rime avec
basile message france à tous tes
commentaires sur benhaim aulas ou la
regarde
voilà un kiff elle est toujours très
belle toujours très belle et oui il peut
pas partir de trop loin pour arriver à
ça va bien je vais vous dire vous aviez
un parcours très petit vous avez très
peu de trash et magnifique à jean michel
mr abbas jean michel mercier va se gâter
leur les années 2000 tient à eau
oui c'était la mode
j'ai trouvé la mode du meeting et toi en
fait je savais pas quoi faire pour
tableau scheer ni comme ils avaient déjà
les vosges il démarré ici c'est le seul
mec la bénèche veille démarrant
serre-tête déconner il démarre dans mort
cette tête là d'un bon je vais chercher
ouais je me cherchais un pressions se
font sur et figaro d'avoir ma fille
c'était nadine bouclin away et là vous
venez d'avoir une fille nous étions
figaro marie née en 2000 j'étais la
bioéthique reporter de guerre là je
n'étais plus c'était à caen j'ai fait
reporter le reste à france soir là
j'étais chef du service se mêlaient six
mois six mois un reporter de gates en a
8 ans partie de l'interview mais c'est
important mais merci mais non j'ai été
dix ans françois il dit au figaro
c'est comme ça car françois j'étais
reporter tu avais prêté 8 ans au figaro
parce que tu mets ton si mal disons oui
c'est vrai c'était pas chipoter 9 ans
pourtant merci kelly vdev dit qu'est ce
qu'elle faisait balader huit ans
[Applaudissements]
kelly b novelli déjà là à dos difficile
c'est sûr et certain
non là c'est vrai sont rigoler c'est
l'adapt avait lui tôt j'avais 10 ans et
les femmes d'espèces girl j'ai savouré
ol disant énormément là dans cinq
minutes ya le grand frère qui arrive à
la main à la pâte min vous étiez ça je
peux travailler bien je travaillais pas
très bien mais j'étais sage
ah d'accord c'était une fausse sage en
fait j'étais un peu c'est ça elles
étaient mis en jeu ni démon un espèce de
caprice des dieux a alors on a quand
vous bonsoir monsieur est away aulas
quoi quoi ce qui faisait vous aviez 13
ans celui 500c les années collège
j'ai regardé notre ami benjamin castaldi
faire sa première au loft way
aujourd'hui les mini comme un mélange un
peu clubs de haut un peu de tout mais
non mais je vous demander ce que vous
faisiez dans la vie de la ville est 6e
5e 4e 3e
non non non
[Rires]
qu'est ce que racontent aux quatre coins
comme et tutoie déjà bas j'ai fait l
littéraire
ouais une licence infos comme un master
2 infocom et herbes hautes et des trucs
même les missiles à vous le croyez pas
mais c'est vrai mais il a dit tu vas
nous appeler on va voir ça te tais tu
veux
du coup elle a des frères plutôt joli
aux téléspectateurs soir c'est une
spéciale années 2000 on se rend compte
pendant ce prime en fait depuis que
depuis dix ans maxime gagne est un gros
mytho se mitonne surtout nous appelons
c'est un tome i j'ai 13 ans il a 50 ans
et la fin des années 2000 parce que toi
on en tue prend 10 puis 11 janvier 2010
à des 13 ans en décembre
c'était mon premier festival
international du télévision de
monte-carlo échec aux côtés d'un acteur
américain qui joue dans la série b
l'acteur américain eddie je suis à côté
de maxime gainey s'est il demandé
gilles verdez internet sous tente et
celle toute façon c'est sûr à malley
frère teddy enlevé
on dirait un pêcheur est mort de la main
on dirait en europe si vous avez zappé
vous des tâches thalassa survenue bon
vin s'engagent à n'être jamais reconnu
c'était des anges et bombay alors oui eh
ben je venais de revenir aux parisiens
en 2000 comme un responsable du service
des sports et j'allais devenir rédacteur
en chef du parisien pour pour quelques
harass et ouais
[Applaudissements]
et c'est pour ça que j'aime fille très
intelligente mais c'est pas parce qu'on
est bon qu'on intelligent on a fait une
grande carrière
on n'a pas le droit d une grande dans le
public n'a pas eu à césar non plus comme
lui j'entends des bravo vous êtes
splendide mérici trop chaud c'est vrai
ce cas oui votre nouvelle coiffure vous
sentez que ça décolle eu beaucoup
beaucoup de compliments maintenant pas
de mal à ça passera à l'acte mais
attention il ya un faux documents sont
le début peut-être de développer une
histoire d'amour j'avais pas l'habitude
de tout ça donc ils font ça ça variées
vous allez prendre alors joue bien ça
c'est un truc comme ça c'est quand ça se
déclenche alors tout se déclenche en
même temps c'est vrai mais là ça va être
un des fers l'eau à mes jolies un
déferlement beaucouzé quoi vous dans les
années '90 que j'étais à france 2 mais
je l'étais qu'assistante programmatrice
j'avais pas encore fait de telle est ma
retraite
on n'aime pas tout vous paraître c'est
la même
[Applaudissements]
et à côté c'est pinocchio cette photo
est vraiment de l'année 2000 que j'ai
trouvé une barricade et parce qu'il est
sympa et je les connais vous avez connu
geppetto à ma mère l'aiment beaucoup et
j'ai pris des photos il ya un truc ça
devait rappeler chose ou plutôt il y
avait un truc qui a filé et son nez
s'allonge et à son fils une fille gptc
bon delphine wespiser oui merci d'être
là delphine ici alors les cheveux
assortis à la robe c'est magnifique
ouais franchement alors regardez
delphine des finales ah ouais en 2000 on
demande une photo d'elle dans les années
90 on voit une photo de son chien
non mais quatre mois la salade
impossible qu'on repousse son chien
thèse à a
non maintenant et tu faisais quoi tu
t'habilles but étant quelque 7 8 ans je
pense en cm2 ouais et et à chaque fois
après les cours je faisais du vélo avec
mes copains avec ma bande de copains et
tout et tout et on prenait le plein air
enfin le grand air et c'est beaucoup je
passais beaucoup de temps qu'avec mes
animaux c'était super bass et je suis
très beau très beau merci
matthieu delormeau matthieu delormeau
atteindra les années 2000 noire 7e titre
qu'est ce qui pourrait vous que la prod
m'a demandé des photos maintenant voyez
vous savez ce qu'ils m'ont répondu ça
fera pas rire sert il parce que t'es
trop beau à cette époque là j'étais
mannequin chez dit ben badi et un
quartier lit on se connaissait tettey et
était dans ma vie j'avais cette chance
unités pendant les années 2000
oui finance finance et ban ki nord
finance ou faisait danser des financiers
des analytes analystes financiers non
non c'est vrai c'est vrai vous étiez
trader oui absolument qu'un trader
chinois
[Rires]
et le canada ont des bas de chaque
circuit des traders le salami a commencé
en a reçues du piquet je me vois
indiquent elles mêmes photos et maudit
noms et mots ni vraiment et photos sont
belles ça fera pas rire oh la la
ouais on dirait spock
[Applaudissements]
l'attelage à 2001 il est en effet
beaucoup plus beau maintenant vous avez
une tête de con très sympa et vous êtes
beaucoup plus beau maintenant c'est fait
là vous faites méchant aujourd'hui vous
faites gentil way fait de missions des
clefs d'or alors moi j'ai une photo de
moi dans les années 2000 je le dis je
t'ai chômeurs et vous le savez c'est
vrai
[Applaudissements]
la bnm kg de thé mignon là mais vous
étiez je suis en livrons pas du tout
mais je vous ai tient un jeudi car ça
leur met la mercerie magnifique mais
vous avez pris un petit peu de poids
ouais bah oui mais c'est normal ça va
laisser des menaces et du sahara alors
je veux qu'on vous est déjà pris aux
traîtres à l'autre jour j'en mets lot
ses côtés m'ont battu